in connections which may happen at
different points in different movies the
the important thing is that these
connections are emotional connections
they're not just silly set pieces to
continue the comedy it's important
especially important for a comedy
comedies need to at some point slow down
tell the truth drop the facade in
Groundhog Day that that moment happens
after Bill Murray has convinced treated
at something that something weird is
happening to her to him and he convinced
her because he goes through everybody in
the cafe and he tells tells me to all
their stories because he's known them
for so long he's he seen their stories
for so long and afterwards they go back
to I guess his hotel room and they're
just talking to each other on on the on
the bed and and he's saying you know I I
wake up and it's the same day and and
she says to him well maybe it's not a
curse you know I'd love to live a
thousand different lifetimes he says
boys you're a perky lady and later that
night she's asleep and he's reading
French poetry to her because he's found
out that she likes French poetry and he
starts to open his heart to her and the
funny story is that this part was
written into the script because Bill
Murray told Harold Ramis about the time
it after he got married and his wife and
he got to wherever they were going to
honeymoon it was really late the wife
went to sleep and Bill Murray told
Harold Ramis that what he did was while
she was sleeping he was able to kind of
open his heart to her and tell her
everything that was on his mind and in
his heart and he was able to do that to
her sleeping that he wasn't able to tell
her
to her face and Howard Ramos and Danny
Reuben put it right into the script and
so it's this beautiful sequence in
Groundhog Day where it's just the truth
he's just telling her what he feels
there's a similar moment in in spy when
having gotten to the villains lair
she and and everybody's holding a gun
and everybody else she simply reveals to
to Jude Law I love you I've always loved
you I yeah who wants to fitness in a
basement filled with you know vermin and
rats I would have quit that a long time
ago but I just wanted to be around you
and and so it's the moment when when
things slow down people start to really
share what's in their hearts with each
other Michael Haig calls this the
getting naked moment in many romantic
comedies happens about halfway through
in inspired happens about 3/4 of the way
through just before the race to the
finish and in in spy she tells Jude Law
exactly what she's thinking in Tropic
Thunder
it's a moment about halfway through when
for the first time Ben Stiller and
Robert Downey jr. start talking to each
other and the Ben Stiller's talking
about how he did this serious film
called simple Jack and he was kind of a
stout of the Oscars you know the Oscars
didn't come many love and Robert Downey
jr. says well I mean you know why and
says no why does Robert Jennings you
said no come on you know why Ben Silla
says no Wyatt
cuz and that's that's the whole sequence
when Robert Downey jr. says well you
went full you can't go full turn
you can go half you can't go full
ah and it's it's a very silly
sequence and you know in a very non-pc
ways
it's funny but it's also the first time
in the movie that these two characters
have actually talked to each other spend
time with each other shared with each
other so so it connections to that
moment of the comedy where you can slow
the comedy down people have to just say
what's on their minds tell the truth as
Michael Haig says get naked not
necessarily naked physically but naked
emotionally
you